hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today
mansion a question from one of our
newsletter readers avi Nash who wrote
insane hi Evan I love your emails and I
read them carefully I'm a student of mba
program and i also want to be an
entrepreneur i want to start a one-stop
shop graphics and animation studio as my
life ambition but it'll take me a long
time to get some experience in the field
so i want your suggestions for young
entrepreneurs thank you avinash so
thanks for the question great question I
think the very first step for any
entrepreneur who wants to get started is
to figure out what type of business that
they want to run and you always want to
build it around something you're really
passionate about and so it sounds like
you you've probably found that so if you
have that's great whether it is you know
creating this animation studio or doing
something completely different you want
to make sure you're building a business
around something that you're really
passionate about helping people with the
next step that I usually recommend is go
out and work for somebody else has
already done it and so this could be
where your next step is if you're you
know graduating your program and you
know you're not ready to start up your
own business quite yet but you want to
learn a little bit more about it go work
for somebody who's already done what
you're trying to do is one of the
fastest ways to learn so go find
somebody who has a small business so
somebody who's say 10 employees whose in
exactly the same field that you want to
do and go learn from them and get
involved try to do more than whatever
you know your job description is
entrepreneurs always need help and if
you can you know be a keener and show
that you're really interested in eager
and want to learn from them then they'll
give you extra tasks even if it's you
know not paid for those extra tasks or
you're working extra hours you're doing
it because you want to learn right if
you're going to take a job you wanted to
teach you something and not just do it
for the money and I look at it this way
you're you're being paid to learn about
your industry so instead of going out
and trying it yourself and probably
failing because you don't know what
you're doing yet you go work for
somebody else has already done it you're
learning from their mistakes and if
you're making mistakes it's on somebody
else's dime so they're paying you to
make mistakes and they're paying you to
learn about the industry and so it will
do two things
it'll teach you about the industry it'll
give you contacts it'll tell you you
know what you're doing if it's right if
it's wrong you know the the insider
tricks well what kind of team you need
to have how to go out and get customers
all those things and so the more you can
get involved in the whole business and
approach the entrepreneur and see you
want it you want more responsibility you
want to get more involved the more you
can learn from them about the business
then the more success you know you'll
probably have because you've learned on
somebody else's dime but also it'll tell
you if you really want to do this
business or not and often entrepreneurs
get started in the business and I
realized I was just too much work or
this isn't what I thought it was going
to be and they lose a lot of money and
time and have to shut down and there
you're frustrated and then in debt and
so by going to work for somebody else is
already doing what you want to do it'll
give you the understanding of what that
business is like and you know you can
look at that entrepreneurs life you know
do you like how they live their life do
you like their lifestyle and the hours
are working and the type of things that
they're producing is that the life that
you want and it may be yeah that's an
awesome life I want that or no that's
crazy i didn't i didn't think it would
be this much work or it wasn't what I
thought it was and so again you're
learning while getting paid and they'll
tell you that's the right business to do
or not and so that's usually my
recommendation for getting started first
find something you're really passionate
about that you feel you can help other
people out a lot of value to their lives
and then try to go find somebody who's
already done what you're trying to do a
smallish company 10 employees or so
where you can really learn the industry
get some experience get some contacts
and see if it's something that you want
to do or not before you go out and
launch your own business and when you do
you'll have a lot of the experience that
you'll need by working because you've
worked for that other company so
hopefully that helps is your next step
up in osh good luck with finishing your
program and launching your own business
for those are you watching if you liked
it please give it a thumbs up below
makes you want to do more these videos
for you and you have a question about
your business feel free to leave it in
the comments below I always read those
and I try to respond to all of them if I
can so thank you and I'll see you in the
next episode
you